what is going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder I'm Warren Thompson
thanks for stopping by the channel today
and with all of this talk surrounding
Jonathan majors and his role as Kang the
Conqueror and the MCU we found out that
it is entirely possible that Marvel
Studios could move away from Kang the
Conqueror being the main villain and if
this does happen Dr Doom would be the
perfect villain to replace him and
actually I believe could be an even
bigger villain than Kang could ever be
and the best part is is Marvel Studios
could do this in a way written in the
MCU that makes complete and perfect
sense and they could also do it in a way
to where can could still be around they
wouldn't have to get rid of Kang the
character completely now let me just
state that it doesn't seem like Marvel
Studios has made any decision in regards
to recasting Jonathan Majors as king or
moving away from the character however I
have had this thought about Dr Doom way
before any of this Jonathan major stuff
has happened and I think that no matter
what Dr Doom should be in secret Wars
and the comic book fans I'm sure know
why but having Dr Doom come into the MCU
and the Fantastic Four and in secret
Wars and possibly some other projects
could be way bigger than Kang could ever
be and they could set him up not only to
be a villain of Secret Wars but also the
true big bad of the next Saga and all of
this could be done in phase six of the
MCU also big thank you to our recent
patrons on our patreon account boss code
dude Catherine Leanne Livingston and
Eddie Johnson thank you all so much for
your support we super appreciate it also
for those supporting our YouTube channel
we're doing a huge giveaway we'll talk
more about that at the end so as I
mentioned if you are a comic book fan or
you have simply heard the stories of
both Secret Wars comic books you know
that Doctor Doom has a massive role in
both of the secret War Stories from the
comics and I believe that this could be
Marvel Saving Grace for Kang if they
need it like I said they could do this
either way it makes sense either way to
throw Dr Doom into the mix and have an
even better more incredible story and
here's how this would work it would
start of course with a Fantastic Four
now if you caught my video yesterday or
you've simply been keeping up with the
news you know that right now Marvel
Studios is kind of pressed for time
right now to make a decision on Jonathan
majors and Kang the Conqueror because
San Diego Comic-Con is coming up this is
where they have a lot of really huge
announcements planned however if they
are going to replace Kang either recast
him or move away from the villain that
has to be decided very soon because that
determines the future of Phase 5 and
phase six and they will have to do some
serious rewrites for some projects if
they want to include Dr Doom but right
now they are riding the Fantastic Four
as we speak the script is not done
everything is coming together for the
Fantastic Four right now which is
awesome we're expecting a cast
announcement at San Diego Comic-Con
hopefully fingers crossed but Marvel
Studios needs to make an official
decision on what they're going to do but
the Fantastic Four since it's still
being written kind of right now the wga
is on strike but the script is still
being written there is plenty of time to
include Dr Doom in the Fantastic Four
story not as the main villain because
we've heard Galactus and a few or a
couple Heralds are going to be the
villains but as simply a character and
here's how the story could work
perfectly and everything line up in the
Fantastic Four we assume Reed Richards
and the rest of the team are going to be
involved in secret Wars in a really big
way the smartest man alive understanding
Multiverse travel is going to be big and
we've already seen this happen in
Multiverse of Madness we've seen that
Reed Richards in the other Universe
perfectly understood the Multiverse he
even understood that incursions happen
and that people really should not be
traveling to other universes so we know
that Reed Richards understands the
Multiverse and if he doesn't it wouldn't
be that hard for him to catch up with
Doctor Strange could visit the Fantastic
Four and tell Reid Richards what had
happened actually this makes perfect
sense because Doctor Strange knows that
some pretty incredible characters exist
in this universe that he visited and it
would make sense when the Multiverse
problems start to happen that doctor
strange would visit Reed Richards to see
if this person exists in his own
universe so we assume that in the
Fantastic Four some Multiverse talk is
going to happen and this is where they
can introduce Dr Doom and the Fantastic
Four movie they can introduce Dr Doom in
a way that makes him let's just say a
little sus don't introduce him as this
big villain right away but hint that yes
he is indeed going to be a villain it
would be great if they showed him kind
of taking notice of Multiverse work that
Reed Richards has done in the comics
Reed Richards and Victor Von do go to
college together at least one of them
Reed Richards went to a lot of colleges
but they were assigned to be roommates
with each other at hedgeman University
however Dr Doom immediately took a
dislike to read and he found another
place to live but it would make sense
for them to show this in the Fantastic
Four movie and it would be great if Reed
Richards started to study the Multiverse
in this college where Doctor Doom was
around so Dr Doom could take notice of
the Multiverse work that Reed Richards
was doing and show us basically that Dr
Doom has a great interest in the
Multiverse work just giving us a little
tease that Dr Doom could perhaps show up
somewhere else in the Multiverse Saga
and that's all we really need before
diving deep into what happens in secret
Wars and if you do want to get more
familiar with the comics and read these
secret War Stories you can check out my
buddies over at comicbookdirect.com they
have created a website and company that
makes comic book shopping the easiest it
can possibly be they deliver Comics
straight to your door you can get
one-off Comics or you can sign up for an
entire run and get a pretty big discount
if you do so and they'll ship the latest
issue right to your door each week they
have the latest from Marvel if you're
trying to keep up to date with all the
recent projects they have the latest
from DC as well and it's an all-in-one
shop for your Comics everything that you
need in one place you can sign up for a
membership to get free shipping and a
mystery box each month and the next 100
people to sign up get 20 20 off their
first order using the link in the
description down below so a secret Wars
is concerned I would love a god Emperor
Doom this is where in the comics and
Secret Wars Dr Doom stole the power of
the beyonder this basically happened in
both Secret Wars and the next Secret
Wars he took the power of the beyonders
and basically with the power of the
beyonders he became a God he killed all
of the heroes with simply a thought and
this is what could happen in our secret
wars in the MCU he could take the power
of Kang who has all of the multiversal
power in the MC right now Kang the
Conqueror and his variants the Council
of Kang has the most power and I'm
assuming one of those kings is most
likely going to be a prime King but
here's the thing Kang is just a man he's
not a cosmic being his power comes from
his technology what would happen if Dr
Doom got his hands on that Tech well he
would be even more powerful than Kang
because Doom is actually extremely
gifted and Powerful with magic in fact
in the comics he has been sorcerer
Supreme the strongest Source around the
planet so what happens if you give one
of the most strongest Sorcerers on the
planet the technology of Kang the
Conqueror technology that gives one of
the most powerful Sorcerers alive the
ability to travel the Multiverse well
all of a sudden you have a human playing
God With God Powers this could be an
even bigger threat and would be an even
bigger threat than just simply Kang the
Conqueror and this could definitely lead
to a great story where the other
variants of Kang actually are going to
fight against Dr Doom while at the same
time The Avengers The Fantastic Four the
X-Men they're all trying to fight Doctor
Doom as well and even if you defeat
Doctor Doom then you have to deal with
Kang and his variants this could make
for an insanely epic story a story that
could probably not be told in one movie
but there has been reports and rumors
that they are thinking about splitting
Secret Wars up into a two-part movie
anyways which to be honest I do think
they should do to not rush through
anything but if Marvel Studios does
decide to replace Kang as the main
villain of the MCU I think Dr Doom would
be the perfect replacement for this
specific reason right here now no doubt
they have plans to introduce Dr Doom at
some point in time probably after the
Multiverse Saga but in terms of MCU
continuity and a story that actually
makes sense I think this would be the
best bet for Marvel Studios but if you
have any other ideas of what they can do
please let us know your thoughts and
your theories in the comments down below
and be sure to let me know what you
think of my idea about Dr Doom as well
please don't forget to like the video
and if you subscribe and leave a comment
you're entered in our giveaway for a
chance to win an Xbox series X A PS5
some Marvel Legends items or some DC
items the winner gets to pick one item
and we pick a winner at the end of each
month also we now have a patreon account
we have a full website where we post you
every day and we also have a Discord
server so we'll link all of those down
below if you're interested also don't
forget to follow us on Instagram and
Twitter and as always thank you all so
much for watching woof woof